i'm i'm going to cite jim cramer on this
and i want to show i want to talk a
little bit about a little bit of
economics okay
jim cramer said the best numbers of our
lives
in reference to this uh the stock market
unemployment all of these things under
trump before kovid
you know just broke everything down and
the democrats locked down
all of these you know basically locked
everything down and they're arresting
people who dare try to run their
business
there's one there's a couple things that
say to me it's not at
all about covid
there was a woman who was live streaming
on facebook products in her store
and saying i'm going to show you tell me
what you
you know what you want and then i can
mail it to you the police were sent in
to shut her down
what i'm not kidding yeah that's
ridiculous a while ago
no idea she said we're close they were
they were like ma'am you have to you
have to close she goes we are closed
can't you see the sign and they're like
yeah but you're
you're doing you know stream to sell
stuff and she's like yes i'm in my
building with door closed people what
they were like nope you have to stop man
so so that makes me think of that tweet
that aoc tweeted that everyone keep
larry larry david just or not larry
david
uh sorry uh man what is his name
uh who who did uncle tom the movie i i'm
spacing around
shoot larry elder thank you yeah so
larry elder just tweeted this and people
are hitting me up like whoa is this real
and it's that aoc tweet that's saying
yeah look we just got to keep the
economy down
because it'll help if it rebounds it'll
help trump get reelected
and it's just like i think it's fake
it's fake
i know i know right there's no proof
that it's a real thing but
but but man does it make sense that
that's i mean what you you're just
saying
take a look at the source like why are
they trying to do this take a look at
the source
it's clear that they want to keep the
economy down because
that's what trump is known for he built
an amazing economy like we were churning
money everyone was making money
news 12 new jersey police interrupt
business owner as she was selling items
on facebook live
wow a small business owner who had to
close her non-essential business says
that she has had several runs with
police while she tried to make some
money the latest incident came
while catherine hermes was conducting a
shop from home style facebook live
from her country home country home store
in downtown bernardsville hermes
and a friend were inside the store both
not wearing masks showing off the
products to viewers who can purchase
them online
police showed up around 9pm on tuesday
police told hermes
that it had to be closed after 8pm and
that she and her friend needed to have
masks on
hermes defied the executive order
forcing her to close when she opened her
store to customers last saturday
she did physically open her store uh at
one point
but this was her doing a live stream
could you imagine if right now the cops
shut up and said yo
business is shut down what do you think
you're doing talking on the internet i
think the internet would
would riot did anybody write for her i
didn't know about it till right now
i covered it when it happened i talked
about it and i said
well to be fair i don't watch all of
your your segments no i know i know but
listen
this is not about this is not about
coven no it's definitely not
a little old lady okay i'm exaggerating
you know a woman running her business
yeah i think she's like a boomer or
middle-aged
and she's live-streaming products and
they show up
and say shut it down you can't do this
what's crazy how is she spreading covet
by selling stuff on the internet i know
i order stuff from amazon all the time
yeah what's the difference
amazon is being bolstered their stock is
going way up because they're the only
thing left
and now i'm going to show you what's
going on so here's my ultimate point
before as we get into this
yeah jim kramer best numbers of our
lives out of joe biden and donald trump
who do you think
is going to help fix the economy i have
literally no reason to believe
joe biden can do anything to help the
economy
and all of the things i don't like about
trump are irrelevant when it comes to
who knows how to make money sorry
it's gonna be it's it's it's not gonna
be joe biden no
which brings me out of the more serious
stuff i've been seeing lately check this
out
bitcoin price rises above three percent
rise i'm sorry rises three percent
as gold trades above two thousand
dollars for the first time
i have no idea what it means that gold
is above two thousand for the first time
but i can tell you
that i have seen gold and silver go way
up recently look at this gold prices
surge midday tuesday to reach an
intra-day record
above 2013 silver jumps nearly five
percent
what what is silver currently trading at
27 26 27 yeah from 22 just the other day
oh my gosh wow man check this out
early stage mortgage delinquencies hit
21
year high this stuff is freaky news man
that's crazy so listen i've talked to a
lot of people about why you gotta buy
your gold people
and they're always telling me different
things i've heard from some people that
people are buying gold right now because
they're not confident in the us economy
so they're based you basically you look
at this way you've got two platforms
that are going up and down
and you want to stay floating so
everybody's jumping over to hard metals
because they retain their value right
because they think dollar is going to
drop
people can't pay their house pay for
their houses people
are uh i think it's what is it 21-year
high
this spike caused an overall mortgage
delinquency rate to jump to 6.1 from 3.6
in march
interrupting 27 straight months of
declines according to a report from
corelogic
so we're now entering the the 2008
territory
apparently we're worse than the great
depression or whatever what happens next
a lot of people think that you know once
this is all over
once the lockdowns end everything
recovers but they're telling a second
wave
and they're telling us to lock down
again they're trying to make sure these
businesses are crushed
completely yeah it sounds like it the
economy is going to be in the gutter and
that's why people are jumping ship
i don't know what their plan is but i'll
tell you what for me at least
doesn't make me confident in joe biden
makes me absolutely more scared that joe
biden would win
yeah what what what what would make
anybody think he's going to fix the
economy especially when we're seeing all
this insanity
true that no trump is the econ economics
guy yeah
what happened with new york in the in
the 80s or whatever in 1983 when he
finished the trump tower i mean he
he convinced a lot of rich people to
move in
and that increase of money like one
apartment sold for 10 million dollars
new york got the taxes from that
so all these taxes that he dragged in
when he finished that building
i mean crime was crazy in new york in
the 70s so
so when that happened like he he i mean
donald trump
changed new york city with that tower he
changed it
that all the rich people that moved in
all of a sudden they were there
yep bolstered the tax base yes he did
exactly what's happening in new york now
oh can we talk about that next
that's a good perfect segue all right so
check check this out this
this is from what is this fox news cuomo
calls on wealthy new yorkers
to come back to the city i'll buy you a
drink
truly truly you did this to yourself
cuomo
and de blasio to be fair cuomo has made
more mistakes
you know he's made tons of mistakes true
but he has been repeatedly saying for a
long time he does not want to raise the
taxes on the rich they're already really
high and he needs them to stay
yeah because he knows exactly what
you're talking about with donald trump
the net tower
inviting the rich people to come to new
york under this you know it was hip
it was popular you want to live in this
building it was luxury it was cool
it's still a nice building oh definitely
i heard he's got a golden toilet
is that true i don't know i want to uh i
want to use it though
i mean who doesn't right exactly anyway
anyway
rich people moved in it bolstered the
tax base it resurrected this city i was
watching a documentary about it
this is why cuomo is begging them to
come back they're not coming back
no why would they if you have to be
insane to go back to bill de blasio
new york city absolutely that guy's nuts
yeah i feel bad for that city
i i spent half of my life there i i love
i have a
big love for new york but not not
anymore like i i see what they've done
to the city and
what they're they don't care about the
people in the city that's all i see
you know what makes me really angry i've
never been
a maga person no i've never i i sit back
in my chair
in 2016 when the trump people and
hillary people were all yelling and when
trump won
i just laughed yeah because like you
tell me the comeuppance of the snooty
elites
but i didn't vote i don't care i'm like
i don't i'm i'm not i'm not getting
anything to do with this but now
i'm really angry the democrats have
forced me into a position
where it's like you've finally done it
you've finally done it i gotta climb off
this thing this fence it's really tall
okay i've been sitting on this fence
minding my own business and i gotta
climb down
and go you know press a vote button
because i look at the history
donald trump launches trump tower
bolsters the tax base in new york city
hey that makes sense the city starts
making more money it works yeah
donald trump gives us the best account
best economy of our lives according to
jim cramer i can't deny that i'm like
yeah the past 70 years
couple people's lives the data was there
the data said unemployment was at a
massive low for all for even from
marginalized communities
we were seeing you know businesses doing
better and better and i was like
i can recognize that but i'm still kind
of like whatever i have no incentive to
get involved
now the democrats are literally burning
everything in the ground yep they're
they're the ones shutting things down
i am being forced to leave this state
because of the insane governor of new
jersey this guy is nuts
who's other another one that has blood
on his hands because he's
putting people in these nursing homes do
they think i'm stupid do they think i
don't
like people like listen yes tim they
they definitely do
right they think the american public is
stupid
but this is the point i'm making is i
run a business
i run a bunch of businesses i gotta do
ton of research i gotta i gotta talk to
lawyers all the time i gotta read the
news all day i mean for me it's look i
get it
the guy who's selling you know chairs at
a furniture store
doesn't have to read the news all day
but people who run businesses are paying
attention
probably to a greater degree to
understand what the new regulations are
can i sell can i sell these chairs
anymore because they pass this new law
yeah and they're seeing they're seeing
the governor of new jersey and
pennsylvania and and and new york
going i i'm not i don't know about cuomo
himself but the mayor of new york going
out and marching
with these protesters just after they
burned down a bunch of
a bunch of parts of their cities yep and
they're going what
or that billion dollar company that
moved to texas or moved to arizona
yeah from seattle seattle it was a bill
it was a billion dollar hedge fund so i
don't know what they're
right they managed a lot of they're no
longer in seattle yep they're in phoenix
now
so how could how could we how could
anyone look at all this
and think joe biden is going to save us
from this crisis when he doesn't even
make appearances
and he's b he can barely you know create
a solid sentence
that's coherent like i i never
understand what he's saying
it's always just a joke to me like wow
it's kind of
fun like trying to figure out what he's
saying so so so what are what are our
options do we
do people really think like hey vote for
biden so everything can burn to the
ground
right it's like okay look i understand
trump's got
you know what did what did sargon say
about him his
because they don't like his uh his
diction right i'm like that's one way to
put it
but he's he's not the character uh you
know
there's a lot i could talk about but
it's not it's not it's i don't care to
rehash all this stuff well this
is the whole thing about this is this
will be biden's america
and that's true they're like well it's
trump's america now
and it's like no those are the democrats
doing that what are you talking about
well these people it's it's a bit more
complicated
the the shield wall of moms are the
democrats yeah who would vote for biden
and antifa hate biden and hate liberals
and hate democrats but will use them as
human shields to advance their ideology
yeah
the reason why that's by biden's america
not trumps america
is because in trump's america he deploys
dhs to go bolster the us marshals at the
courthouse and defend federal property
and then you have the marxist leader
that straight up says well biden is more
malleable
and will bend the knee exactly we say if
we
riot biden's going to fall asleep yeah
and i don't
i don't even care if it's biting at this
point because let's open it operate the
assumption it won't be biden okay
for whatever reason i don't know by the
end of the month it's not going to be
biden
we'll see but i don't care who it is
when you get these democratic senators
like merkley
every word out of his mouth just a lie
he could say the word thought i bet
you're lying
i don't believe you he did this he did
this hearing where he's like the
peaceful protesters and trump's secret
police with unmarked blah blah i'm like
none of that is true
none of that is true so you've you've
pissed me off
now i gotta climb off this fence i'm not
happy about it okay i don't wanna i
don't wanna be involved i'll tell you
this
the economy is in shambles and i'll tell
you what man you know who's the least
person affected by it me
because i do an internet show where i
talk about politics and as long as
politics are churning
my business is is not impacted but i see
all these other people who are telling
stories of torching their furniture
figuratively
their lives are being destroyed they're
struggling we're printing money like
crazy and i'm like dude this needs to
stop
yeah i can easily i got a van i can go
live down by the river be fine for the
rest of my life but
what about all the other people who
don't know where they're going to go who
don't have money for food
we need someone to fix this problem now
you got me sitting there going like
you know the only person who can do it
is trump
yep joe biden is a disaster he's a
disaster
when it's not even about policy and so
now i'm sitting here looking at new york
and this is the best example
cuomo begging the rich people to come
back yep okay
okay is he gonna beg trump to come back
trump come help us right they've been
begging for bailout money
i'm sorry man these these these it's
it's it's gotten so ridiculous
anyway i don't know this is this is i
i'm looking at the
aren't they setting up some uh some
borders you have to be quarantined for
like
two weeks what's going on with that i
think i have that uh right here
oh new york city to set up quarantine
checkpoints at city borders
this is going to fix it who who would
want to live in this place
nobody that doesn't make any sense i
know seriously
well i mean it makes sense in a certain
capacity but it's going to jam
everything up and it's going to be a
nightmare for the people who have to
come in and out of that place do you
remember when sandy hit new york
yeah you were living there too right
yeah i i got a cool story one of the bus
stops fell over
and people were skating on it oh dope
yeah they were grinding on the top of it
it was cool
so the city of new york for the three
days that they shut down
lost two billion dollars in revenue two
billion
two days from tourism and just
shopping and taxes of everything so you
can imagine like how long have has new
york been shut down now
two four five five five months
so two days they lost two billion
dollars in revenue they won't
they can't recover bro they cannot
recover especially because all the rich
people moved out and now they're
quarantining anyone that comes into the
city
how are they going to get away from how
can they bounce back from that they
can't
and i've seen an estimate that one-third
of small businesses will not come back
yep they're just gone they're gone
forever in new york or across the new
york city
exactly new york's new york's done yeah
ladies and gentlemen what's this
i give you oh boy new york city oh i
want to read it
new york's wealthy upper east side
reports a shocking
286 percent increase in robberies
with armed gunmen holding up residents
just feet
from the homes of billionaires wow
wow i didn't know this when is this from
yesterday
wow yeah dude 286 percent increase
well i got a buddy who who dipped at the
beginning of
march she was like i'm i'm out me and my
family
were dipping they got rid of their
apartment they moved
they moved out poor new york man that's
what i'm hearing from pretty much
everyone i know that lives in new york
yeah i'm hearing from a lot of people
they're getting out of cities
yeah i was i'm i was talking to a
progressive friend of mine in l.a
and they're like how you been what's new
and i'm like just getting getting as far
away from cities as possible and they
were like i dig it i
could totally do the same thing yeah
it's an issue of can they afford do the
same thing exactly yeah
now that's that that's why i think we're
in desperate need of someone who can
solve this problem
and that's why i say i'm like really
angry with the democrats
that they could have literally chosen
any viable candidate
from a whole slate of people and you can
disagree with them on policy but
i'll tell you what for all the things
you might disagree with some of these
other democrats about
even kamala harris like you can think
she's i think she's nasty i think she's
very evil
i think she's very corrupt my opinion of
her but at least she's like
capable of speaking english yep you know
at least she's honest about wanting to
use slave labor seriously
they said there was an article joe
biden's vp will be the most powerful vp
in the history of this country
maybe that's the goal i guess and it's
going to be kamala
you know you think so that's who you're
betting i mean politico you know did
that
people people like accidentally publish
that it was yeah but remember
that's if biden is the dnc's choice
which i just don't think that's going to
be the case i don't know what's going on
with these people and that's why i'm
like listen
even if it was tulsi gabbard
even if it was andrew yang or pete booty
judge donald trump still has the
economic experience yes he does
and that's that that what's your
argument against that that he's a bigot
that he's nasty these racists i'm like
that's true but how many people need to
starve to death because you don't like
the opinions
it's not even true no the point i'm
saying is if they're going to call trump
racist i'll be like okay
so how many people should starve to
death because you don't like the way the
president speaks right
what's your what's your answer so we we
had like what was it i think it was the
world health organization i'm not sure
saying like 250 million people are going
to starve to death
due to the shutdowns and people are
cheering for it and i'm like listen
what how many people are going to die
from from covid versus starving to death
because of the economic shutdown right
how many are you okay with
i see that you've put on a hat oh well
there's a reason oh
is there a reason no beanie no peace
yes no beanie no peace i got you chat
i got you we get it and you got me thank
you my goodness
we nailed it
no beanie no peace great work everyone i
love this chat
our our fans are the best i love you all
you guys are all fantastic thanks for
coming here with us because
it's not the same without having you
guys all here and now that we're
and now to bring you back to the the the
despair
thanks tim i'm definitely i love my boss
check it out
250 million people could be pushed to
the brink of starvation by end of year
united nations yeah the economic effects
of the covet 19 pandemic will last well
beyond the virus itself
this is in april now they're talking
about shutting down again
this has gone beyond insane and i'm
tired of saying it you know i've talked
to friends where they're like we have to
lock down you know we have
and i'm like dude 15 days to slow the
spread what day are we on 140 yeah
well but but we've had because people
wouldn't wear masks and i'm like okay
but the cases are spiking yeah well the
deaths are still going down that means
it's not that bad
period it's not that bad should 250
million people starve to death
that's basically what they're arguing
for and then you're gonna kill your
grandmother
it's like it's just like with greta
tunberg yep we have to stop all fossil
fuels even if millions of people die
how dare you how dare you we must burn
down the entire
global economy to kill you wrong yeah
she is very wrong
she's not literally saying that not now
now a snope is gonna fact check you know
pop up and be like tim pool claims greta
toomberg says all these people should
die
false timpool lied yeah yeah it's a joke
she's talking about shutting down fossil
fuels which will lead to millions of
people dying
right now the economic lockdown is going
to cause
mass starvation around the world yep and
these people or don't know or don't care
and are happy with it why for tribal
reasons
i'm i'm i am i am flabbergasted is that
the right word yeah that's a great word
i am it is a good word
i am discombobulated also good another
another
uh
what does that mean that's an old snl
reference oh
from uh a bunch of old old ladies chris
farley
it's old yeah i have to look at it i'm
the clump it's when you get all choked
up and can't speak anymore
ah i think that's what i do all right
i'll google it
how do you navigate the space where you
have the democratic party
bending the need of people who don't
know two plus two equals four
gosh i don't know i'm not exaggerating
my friends literally not
i'm i'm i'm not 1984 man there are
the woke on twitter are literally
arguing two plus two
can equal five by they're saying things
like well it
depends on how you your axioms and your
definitions and it's like no no no no no
no no just stop just stop you will never
have a circumstance
where you take two pens and then adam
takes two pens and then poof there are
five pens just like a fifth one just
magically appears actually i guess if
you cross your eyes and like put your
fingers together
a weird third finger appears well you
know when you take two quarters
and then two quarters and then you do
this it kind of is an illusion that
there's three
be six oh that's what i i don't know the
point is
two plus two equals four uh yeah there
are four lights
actually we have six lights yeah that's
not correct but there are four lights a
star trek reference learn how to count
him
come on what what do we do when you have
the republicans
saying the far right like the klan and
these groups are bad and so is antifa
and the left says
well you know there's no antifa that's a
myth and then
the republicans the right the moderates
go two plus two equals four
and the woke left goes actually i can
think of at least three ways to make two
plus two equal five no you can't you can
create a different equation where two
plus two equals five with qualifiers
but the literal equation is is true
because true and false exist
and then you have democrats going
whatever they say on twitter i'll just
repeat and send it
how long it seems like how are you doing
geez that policy how long until a
congress a democratic congress person or
senator goes
joe joe biden got get him and go two
plus two is five listen here
fat two plus two can be five you know
the thing you know the thing
no that won't happen it won't be by now
the they'll lose
the the majority of the middle they
can't they can't risk that
here's what i would like i would like
you know there was a uh
someone made a joke in response to this
two plus two equals five thing that the
woke left is doing okay that anthony
fauci unequivocally announced that two
plus two does in fact equal four and
never equals five
fouchy said that they're making a joke
that if he did they'd be like oh well
then it must be true
and i'm like okay republicans just
passively ask this
um in your expert opinion dr fauci is
there any circumstance where two plus
two could be five
he'll be like no what thank you that's
that's all that was like i don't
understand no don't worry about it you
don't need to understand i just wanted
on the record
yep how many democrats would be like i'm
not answering that question
not kidding probably all of them yep
because they can't risk losing the the
left so few that they think is like the
most
the important voter base that they need
to cater to
it's ridiculous they're they're the
argument that two plus two
can equal five is basically saying that
you can make anything equal
anything by changing the meaning of
words you can and that's
what they've been doing for a long time
they're showing what i'd like to see
i would like to see a video of a
republican or anybody
politely asking a democrat is there any
circumstance in which two plus two could
be five
and then have them say either oh i don't
i don't know you know i'm not gonna you
know
i'm not gonna get involved and then just
have that video go viral yeah there you
go
democrats can't tell you what two plus
two is go vote for them do it
if you want to that's where we're at
right now
that's uh reclaiming my time yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you